quick shout out to those who also drew
Hitler mustaches on my posters by the
way
[Applause]
Oh
it's okay and thank you for coming as
well I hope you enjoyed your experience
by the way that's good news for a few
people in the standby line quick shout
out to people who are drawing Hitler
mustaches on my poster by the way two
problems there
first I'm an Orthodox Jew second I've
been trying to grow facial hair for
years and it's just not working okay now
to the actual topic of this speech
America wasn't built on slavery it was
built on freedom now the reason for this
speech is that we are actually in the
midst of a great internal conflict in
the United States about the very nature
of the country the conflict surrounds a
very simple question are we a nation or
are we not on the one side by many
Americans mostly conservatives who argue
that we are indubitably a nation unified
by history by culture by language the
most contentious part of this statement
is not the part about culture or
language we all basically agree that we
should speak the same language I don't
mean that I'm talking about Spanish
versus English I mean that we should be
able to understand each other when we
have a conversation or culture in which
we sort of understand that we share a
culture we watch the same TV shows and
we experience the same sports and we
have all of these cultural totems the
most contentious part of the statement
is that were unified by our history now
the traditional view of American history
goes something like this America was
built on eternally good and true
principles springing from both the
judeo-christian ethic and English
culture rooted in natural law those
principles were denied in practice by
many of the same people who promoted
them in theory but those theories were
valid and they remain valid today the
story of America therefore is really a
story of the broadening application of
those principles the perfection of our
Union the fulfillment of the promises of
the Declaration of Independence in the
Constitution of the United States that's
the traditional story of what America is
now that view certainly does not tonight
nor should it deny the evils and horrors
of slavery and Jim Crow or the savage
brutality of the dispossession of Native
Americans but this view does recognize a
simple truth the state of the world
historically has been replete with evil
and horror and brutality in America
unlike other nations has fought over
time to wipe them away at home and
abroad in this view the story of America
doesn't begin in 1776 but 1776 does
represent the breaking point with the
past the statement of our cherished
principles the story of America is the
story of a nation conceived in Liberty
and dedicated to the proposition that
all men are created equal then there's
the alternative view of American history
this view suggests that America is not
in fact a true nation America is instead
an agglomeration of competing interests
forced together by circumstance and by
fate damned to interminable struggle
America is a story of exploitation and
greed of patriarchy and abuse of
hierarchy and manipulation America's
story is an unending litany of Horrors
punctuated by brief respite
always sliding back into the damnable
bacterial soup from once we sprang
racism as Barack Obama suggested is in
America's DNA in 2015 the president's
elected by sixty nine point five million
Americans in 2008 explained quote the
legacy of slavery Jim Crow
discrimination is in almost every
institution of our lives you know that
casts a long shadow and that's still
part of our DNA that's passed on
we're not cured of it racism we are not
cured of clearly now Obama's mantle was
picked up this year by the Democrats
second favorite fake minority been
O'Rourke
a man who has not been saying for
cultural appropriation over his name but
happens to be whiter than any person in
America not named Elizabeth Warren sorry
beto cribbing from the new york times
1619 project in his quixotic
question for relevance suggested that
America was founded on racism and
slavery said quote racism in America is
endemic bra it is foundational we can
mark the creation of this country not at
the 4th of July 1776 but August 20th
1619 when the first kidnapped American
was brought to this country against his
will and in bondage as a slave and built
the greatness and success and wealth
that neither he nor his descendants
would be able to fully participate in
and enjoy now lest you think the patos
perspective on America is retrospective
bata brought it up to date in late
October America he said his still racist
at its foundation at its core and
throughout the system and then of course
he became completely irrelevant now he's
off eating dirt in New Mexico or
something by the way it should be noted
that bata said all of this while calling
for Americans to elect him a white man a
very privileged white man to the highest
office in the land
white privilege shaking my damn head so
which is it which values more represents
America the Americans which we all
belong racism and slavery and Jim Crow
or the freedoms posited in the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution of the United States
because both of these things are part of
our history undoubtedly but the question
is which is more defining of the country
of our history and in which we live
obviously and undeniably again slavery
is the darkest part of American history
it was unforgivable horrific brutal
vicious unthinkable but is it the root
of American history or did it represent
a sinful deeply sinful straying from
founding principles rectified over time
was America founded and built on freedom
or on slavery to examine this question
we have to start at the founding to
support the notion that America was
built on slavery advocates of the
revisionist school of historical thought
about the country point out that many of
America's founding fathers were
slaveholders that the Declaration of
Independence didn't abolish slavery and
thus is high-handed declarations of
natural rights and equality among men or
a mirage and that the Constitution
expressly permitted slavery let's take
each of these arguments in turn first
it's undeniable of course that many of
America's founding fathers were
slaveholders you have to begin with the
fact that the time of the founding
Britain had not outlawed slave holding
or the slave trade in its colonies and
would not do so until the British slave
abolition Act of 1833 and would not
outlaw slavery among its charter
companies until 1843 slavery was legal
in Great Britain proper legally until
1807 that means that slavery was
widespread across the planet net the
United States was no exception according
to Henry Louis Gates over the period
1525 to 1866 12.5 million Africans were
shipped to the new world in the
transatlantic slave trade they injured
the unthinkably horrible horrible Middle
Passage many died in transport of
disease starvation or suicide of those
12.5 million human beings approximately
ten point seven million arrives in the
New World
how many of those landed in North
America directly about three hundred and
eighty eight thousand this is not to
excuse a single kidnapping enslavement
or sale of a human being each one of
these was a crime against man and
against God and we all agree on this it
is to point out that the United States
was certainly not unique at the time of
the founding in allowing slave holding
it was common across the planet
including in Western countries with that
said where did the founders actually
stand on the question of slavery
well 41 of the 56 founding fathers who
signed the Declaration of Independence
did hold slaves but the founding fathers
including many people who did hold
slaves were well aware that slavery was
a moral abomination this was the
conflict at the heart of the American
Founding John Adams from Boston stated
my opinion against it has always been
known never in my life did I own a slave
he stated that quote every measure of
prudence therefore ought to be assumed
for the eventual total extirpation of
slavery from the United States Samuel
Adams said but to the eye of reason what
can be more clear than that all men have
an equal right to happiness Benjamin
Franklin became the head of the
Pennsylvania abolition Society after at
one point in his young life owning
slaves and stated quote mankind that
mankind are all formed by the same
almighty being alike objects of his care
and equally designed for the enjoyment
of happiness the Christian religion
teaches us to believe and the political
creative Americans fully coincides with
the position we earnestly entreat your
serious attention to the subject of
slavery that you will be pleased to
countenance the restoration of Liberty
to those unhappy men who alone in this
land of freedom are degraded into
perpetual bondage and who are groaning
in servile subjection John Jay the first
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
stated quote that men should pray and
fight for their own freedom and yet keep
others in slavery is certainly acting a
very inconsistent as well as unjust and
perhaps in pious
J and Alexander Hamilton were among the
men who created the New York manumission
Society in 1787 for the freeing of
slaves governor Morris one of the
founding fathers said slavery was a
quote in farías institution and
described quote the curse of heaven on
the states where it prevailed Benjamin
Rush and other founding father domestic
slavery is repugnant to the principles
of Christianity it is rebellion against
the authority of a common father it is a
practical denial of the extent and
efficacy of the death of a common Savior
it is a usurpation of the prerogative of
the great sovereign of the universe who
has solemnly claimed an exclusive
property in the souls of men George
Washington stated I can only say that
there is not a man living who wishes
more sincerely than I do to see a plan
adopted for the abolition of slavery it
is no wonder the Pennsylvania and
Massachusetts moves to abolish slavery
in 1780 Connecticut and Rhode Island in
1784 Vermont in 1786 New Hampshire in
New York in 1799 New Jersey in 1804 many
of the founding fathers released their
own slaves as well including George
Washington John Dickinson Caesar Rodney
John Randolph and others Thomas
Jefferson is most often cited on the
score because he was indeed a massive
hypocrite on slavery but he was well
aware of his own hypocrisy Jefferson
wrote that slavery destroyed the morals
of the people as well as their industry
in fact Jefferson suggested that slavery
would bring disaster upon the nation
quote indeed I tremble for my country
when I reflect that God is just that his
justice cannot sleep forever whether
considering numbers nature and natural
means alone a revolution of the wheel of
fortune in exchange of situation is
among possible events that it may become
by probable probable by supernatural
interference the Almighty has no
attribute which can take side with us in
such a contest in 1778 Jefferson
actually very early in his career even
introduced a bill to ban importation of
slaves into Virginia hoping for
slavery's quote final eradication this
conflict carried forward into the
Declaration of Independence the original
draft of the Declaration of Independence
included a clause written by Thomas
Jefferson ripping into the British
Empire for supposedly imposing slavery
on the colonies the original clause
suggested quote he this would be King
George the third has waged cruel war
against human nature itself violating
its most sacred rights of life and
liberty in the person's of a distant
people who never offended him
captivating and carrying them into
slavery in another hemisphere or to
incur miserable death in their
transportation there
it was of course southern colonists who
decided that they were not going to sign
on to a declaration of independence that
included such language the Declaration
of Independence and its credo that all
men are created equal was not meant to
exclude slaves philosophically it was
meant to encompass everyone which is why
it was so easy for the Declaration of
Independence to be extended to include
everybody he didn't have to change any
of the language this is why ex-slave and
second founding father yes he should be
on our currency Frederick Douglass
described the great principles contained
by the Declaration of Independence
Douglass stated quote the signers of the
Declaration of Independence were brave
men they were great men too great enough
to give Fame to a great age they
believed in order but not in the order
of tyranny with them and nothing was
settled that was not right with them
justice liberty and humanity were final
not slavery and oppression just
Douglass's great cry for freedom arose
from his invocation of exactly those
founding principles he said quote are
the great principles of political
freedom and of natural justice embodied
in that Declaration of Independence
extended to us that was the question
that he sought to have answered and that
was a question that wouldn't be answered
obviously until the Civil War okay how
about the Constitution of the United
States the argument is made that the
Constitution of the United States is a
slavery document
well the founding fathers actually
believed that they had placed slavery on
the road to extinction even before the
Constitution was written the Northwest
Ordinance side my George Washington in
1787 banned slavery in new territories
those territories would later become the
states of Ohio Indiana Illinois Michigan
Wisconsin Minnesota there were
approximately at the time of the
founding 60,000 free black Americans
living in the United States the
Constitution of the United States bans
importation of slaves beyond 1808 the
infamous three-fifths clause which
counted slaves as three-fifths of a
human being for purposes of
congressional apportionment was designed
to prevent increased slave holding power
that's what it was designed to do it was
not meant to deride black Americans who
was meant to stop slave holding States
from having additional power in the
Congress of the United States because if
you counted slaves fully that would have
boosted southern representation in
Congress without increasing the number
of actual voting citizens the
Constitution of the United States makes
no overt reference to slavery avoiding
enshrining slavery and federal law James
Madison the father of the Constitution
wrote that it would be wrong to place in
the Constitution any admission of the
idea that there could be quote property
in men all of this is why the Frederick
Douglass was
to call the Constitution of the United
States a glorious Liberty document he
thundered read its preamble consider its
purposes is slavery among them is it at
the gateway is it in the temple it is
neither as Lincoln noted in his 1860
cooper unions Cooper Union speech 22 of
the thirty-nine framers of the
Constitution voted on the Northwest
Ordinance 20 voted in favor of the
legislation one of the other one of the
other framers George Washington was the
president who signed it in 1794 the
founders prohibited export of slaves the
selling of American slaves abroad in
1798 they prohibited importation of
slaves into the Mississippi Territory in
1807 Congress effectuated the ban on
importation of slaves codified in the
Constitution a year before they were
even legally allowed to do so so that on
the date of 1808 laid forth in the
Constitution importation of slaves into
the United States would be banned okay
now we move on to the Civil War this
none of this ended the cruelties of
slavery obviously despite the best
efforts and many of the founders slavery
continued to explode in numbers in the
United States those largely due to the
invention of the cotton gin which
suddenly made intensive agriculture in
southern states a worthwhile pursuit
economically by the time of the Civil
War some four million slaves were held
in the United States held by just under
400 thousand slaveholders according to
the United States Census in 1860
southern advocates began to argue the
morality of slavery particularly John C
Calhoun who is a vicious white
supremacist and did serve as vice
president of the United States and they
started to insist that the federal
government enshrined slavery for all
time
forced free states to return escaped
slaves and allow for the expansion of
slavery into New Territories but here's
the thing the story of America is not a
story of unending tolerance for slavery
far from it the intransigent
backwardness of slave holding States led
to the bloodiest war in the history of
America with over 600,000 human beings
dead hundreds of thousands of men
marched into battle singing the Battle
Hymn of the Republic and the lyrics of
the Battle Hymn of the Republic say as
he died to make men holy let us die to
make men free the purpose of the Civil
War was quite clear the original lyrics
by the way we're even more militant they
sense turn around John Brown who's an
abolitionist militant who led a raid at
Harpers Ferry tried to lead a slave
uprising of black Americans at Harpers
Ferry the original lyrics to the Battle
Hymn of the Republic it was called John
Brown's body and the original lyrics
said John Brown's body lies amoled ruin
in the grave his soul is marching on
now it's true that Abraham Lincoln
didn't originally stand in favor of
emancipation his mandate as elected was
to effectuate Union not to free the
slaves but it was obvious what his
agenda was which is exactly why the
South tried to secede right he'd said
all of this in his house divided speech
in 1858 quote I believe this government
cannot endure permanently half slave and
half free either the opponents of
slavery will arrest the further spread
of it and place it where the public mind
shall rest in the belief that it is in
the course of ultimate extinction or
it's advocates will push it forward till
it shall become a like lawful in all of
the states old as well as new north as
well as south and is obvious which side
of that ledger Lincoln came down on as
president therefore Lincoln issued the
Emancipation Proclamation he rammed
through the Republican Congress the
Thirteenth Amendment bar and slavery
weeks later he was assassinated in 1866
the House of Representatives passed the
Fourteenth Amendment guaranteeing equal
protection of the laws the Fifteenth
Amendment guaranteeing black Americans
the rights vote passes Congress in 1869
and so slavery ends in the United States
and due process and equal protection of
the laws is guaranteed at least legally
to those who have been held in cruel
bondage freedom triumphed at least on
paper but freedom didn't of course fully
triumph because in the aftermath of the
Civil War after so-called Radical
Republicans pressed for federal
protection of black Americans the effort
collapsed southern states reinstituted
brutal racist laws the KKK became a
massive force in the south enforcing its
racist evil with the rope and the gun
schemes of segregation and Jim Crow
became the norm in Old Confederate
States sharecropping replaced slavery
legalized terrorism against black
Americans was commonplace and the
federal government did nearly nothing
black Americans pressed on heroically
fighting for the freedoms that they had
been promised in the Declaration of
Independence and then promised again by
Lincoln and the Radical Republicans they
fought for their freedom day in and day
out the right to live free of legally
mandated discrimination their right to
rise economically their right to prosper
in Liberty in Liberty and of course they
met for his amazing tremendous
resistance from awful human beings like
Woodrow Wilson a person who actually
showed the birth of a nation you know
the pro KKK and the pro KKK DW Griffith
film he showed it at the White House to
FDR who signed into law the deeply
flawed GI bill that would deny effective
benefits to black Americans particularly
in the south redlining was common
practice educational opportunities were
barred to black Americans and yet still
black Americans rose the black poverty
rate
from 87% in 1942 47% by 1960 with Jim
Crow in place which is an unbelievable
accomplishment it's an amazing
accomplishment the black middle class
grew and then came the civil rights
movement the most important victory for
freedom over slavery since the end of
the Civil War Martin Luther King jr. of
course of this university led the charge
citing the founders and America's
original ideals on August 12 1963 King
jr. stood on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial perfectly fitting and intoned
the timeless words words that still
shocked us with truth and vision he said
when the architects of our republic
wrote The Magnificent words of the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence they were signing a
promissory note to which every American
was to fall heir this note was a promise
that all men yes black men as well as
white men would be guaranteed the
unalienable rights of life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness I have a dream
that one day this nation will rise up
and live out the true meaning of its
Creed we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal